التطبيقات - تشتهر هولندا
بسكويت الوفل الصارمة أو stroopwafels ، إنها
الماريجوانا
، أعني السلع المخبوزة وهي
سمكة نيئة زلقة لذيذة تُعرف باسم الرنجة ، والأهم من
ذلك أن الهولنديين كانوا يعرفون أن الرنجة
هي سمكة نيئة مقطوعة الرأس ،
أووه هذا سيكون لذيذًا ، وربما يكون هذا هو
الأكثر شهرة  طبق في هولندا
ولكن لفهم لماذا يجب أن نسافر إلى
أصل الأطباق ، مرحبًا بكم في شيفا
لينجام ، المدينة الساحلية المهووسة
بالرنجة التي يوضحها تمثال الرنجة العملاق هذا
، أعني أن
علم مدنهم يحتوي حتى على ثلاثة أسماك رنجة ،
انتظر آسف هذا أمر سيء  على سبيل المثال ،
نذهب إلى
نقود اللحوم ، إنه صاحب سمك
الرنجة ، وهو تلفزيون خاص بالسمك الهولندي النموذجي
من هنا ، نبيعه ،
وأعتقد أن سمك الرنجة معي يتراوح بين مائتين وثلاثمائة ألف
رنجة سنويًا
في نهاية شهر مايو ويبدأ شهر يونيو.
استخدمه طوال العام
وننظفه بالملح وننظف الجلد منه
ونضع كل البراغي وأعتقد أنها
الأسماك الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام لأنها كذلك
صحي للغاية ، فهناك الكثير من فيتامينات
أوميغا 3 و SATA فيه ، لذا فإن الأكل
الذي يأكل يومًا ثم الطبيب يبتعد عنه
هنا هو تاو السيد.  الرنجة طازجة جدًا حتى
تتمكن من الإعجاب مباشرة بعد
التنظيف ، فإن الطريقة المثالية هي الطريقة التي كانت
عليها قبل سنوات من خلال ما زالت وتقضم بصوت عالي ، لذا
دعنا نعود إلى أمستردام هنا ، فهم
الرنجة بشكل مختلف قليلاً ،
والإجابة هي على طبق مقطوع في
قطع مع بعض البصل والمخللات
على الجانب أو في شطيرة واسعة
ولكن لماذا المخللات والبصل مرة أخرى
في الأيام التي لم يجمدوا فيها حتى يحصلوا
على الرنجة طوال العام بأكمله وفي
أوقات الشتاء لم تعد الرنجة
جيدة بعد الآن  لذلك وضعوا بعض البصل
والمخللات لقتل الطعم ، لا يمكن العثور على الطبق
في المطاعم فقط هذه
الأكشاك الباقية الباقية من سمك الرنجة المنتشرة
حول السد منذ 50 عامًا على كل
قطعة كان هناك إنفاق ولكن في الوقت الحاضر ،
هناك سبعة متبقية هنا للإجابة
لذلك نحن المحظوظون
وفازوا بأن السائحين خائفون لأنني
أعتقد أنه روب
[موسيقى]
ولكنه في الواقع منقوع في الماء المالح ،
لذا لم يكن الأمر خاطئًا
ويعتقدون أنهم سيموتون أو
شيء ما ولكن هذا ليس صحيحًا
ولم يمت أحد من الرنجة ، نعم بالتأكيد
أتمنى لي التوفيق
[موسيقى]
أنت